yeah how's it going to Zed carrasco NMR
magazine I would Eric jacobus he's an
independent stuntman an actor who
starred as a striker in moral Kombat
legacy season two on machinima tell us
how you got your role as striker and
moral Kombat legacy uh well uh I'm Eric
jacobus I had known Larnell for a few
years now and Larnell called me up one
day he said you know I think you'd be
right to the striker role why don't you
send in a video you know read some lines
and send a video in and they called me
in you know I'm an actor does his own
stunts and I can do fight choreography
and you know I seem to fit the role
pretty well I mean I'm I kind of play an
underdog typically in the movies that I
worked on striker is that kind of
underdog character he's a human in a
world with a bunch of different
superheroes he just got a gun in a Taser
he doesn't have fireballs and that fit
me really well um so I was really really
happy to be involved in that you mind uh
you know telling us what is his strikers
fatality in this series haha I can't
give that away i'm sorry i love to but
probably probably can't talk about that
now what kind of training do you have to
go through before you prepare before you
started filming for your role uh i mean
i as a general generally a stunt guy
should you know have a good martial arts
background nice i started a little bit
late in life i started when i was 20 so
um but even then you know it's been 10
years of martial arts and i can I can do
whatever I you know whatever's asked of
me but also being able to do basic Falls
that's why you know a lot of martial art
classes already teach Falls which is
great for a stunt person that's why
martial arts and stunt work makes really
well together and and you know like
whatever other miscellaneous skills you
can get like parkour acrobatics it
always helps but in general just the
the ability to do some martial arts and
some falls is it is his ideal but for
the character for striker I did go
through a little bit of like I went
through a little bit of firearms
training I went and I got my you know my
handgun safety certificate in the
process that I figured it would just be
a good idea to do that while I was
playing this character and that worked
out really well now I have that which is
great and and also when we were
choreographing choreograph from the
fight you know we were using different
weapons in the choreography and in
Larnell would drill me on those weapons
and I learned a little bit of Tong fo
from a karate guy that I work with and
yeah walk us through a typical day on
the set of moral Kombat legacy well we
would get up at around I get up around
five cuz call times at 5 45 and my buddy
Kim who plays a her Mac he would drive
me to to set and we would go in there we
get made up for about an hour the first
day I got my haircut on set there you
know in the in the makeup trailer and
and that in the makeup is kind of like
the part where you can catch some sleep
too I mean because we would go to bed it
maybe one or two in the morning and we'd
get up at five to do these really early
call times and the early call time was
because we had to shoot in the daylight
we couldn't just shoot in the studio so
we were limited on time and so like in
the in the makeup chair you could kind
of like sleep a little bit and then you
you know cracked looks like the fun time
of the day you know where its kind of
relaxed and you'd see other cast members
come in like that's where i met casper
van dien and now it's kind of like
sitting in the makeup chair and they got
aphro nice to meet you know and uh and
and then after that we get suited up
with our outfits going to the trailer
get all our stuff on walk up the set by
the time that I don't know about around
seven-thirty we'd get up to the actual
location which was underneath for my
sins it was underneath the Hollywood
sign in LA and block it out for a little
while and that the crew was like all
ready to go by the time I got there I
mean everybody was just kind of waiting
there for us and Kevin already had his a
kit already had some
some extra guys setting up shot like
they're they're doubling me and the
other actor and they're already lining
up the shot and they already knew what
shots they need and they said okay
striker uh if they need anything else on
me like Oh today I don't have the Taser
we'd like to fix all that stuff real
quick and the prop people would be all
over me and then suddenly I'd be I would
look different and in that go over to
the spot and within about 30 minutes we
would shoot it was quick it's a lot
quicker than I'm used to and you know we
do like three or four takes or so and
nail it hit some more angles move on and
you know typical breaking taking a break
for lunch lunch was awesome because they
have this great like great catering
service there and we would all eat and
sit down you know talking David end at
five and then we get cleaned up and get
out of there go home party go to bed
really late but all in all the fights
had had already been choreographed so we
didn't have to really go over the fights
very much like we really just we already
memorized the entire thing yeah they
were broken up into segments and so
before the shoot a few weeks before
Lauren owl and me and whoever else is
doing the fights we would choreograph it
and we get the sections and then on set
you know we would say okay we're doing
section one and then we'd shoot it we
cut and then let's do section one again
and they would get a different sector
than a different shot of the action than
they would cut and we do that till the
fight was done how was moral Kombat
legacy been different from all the other
projects you've done in the past my
projects have typically been under a
million dollars each so we do very like
low-budget independent action films and
so the schedules tend to be a little bit
more relaxed I mean some days we go
there and we you know we work on a fight
scene and it's a little bit slow we take
our time to kind of improvise a lot and
then we're also kind of strained on
resources we don't you know we sleep on
the floor you know that's typical of
indie filmmaking one upon my legacy is
like the real deal you know it's over a
million I don't know how much but I know
that there are a lot of people people
there on set whenever I needed you know
if I said I need a knee pad that kind of
hold my hand out and then it would just
be in my hand you know like that kind of
stuff happens when you're working on
really good sets and when you're working
with really good people too and all the
people on this there were like 82 there
must've been 80 people on set and and
that's that's that's a big deal for
someone that's you know typically
working with a crew of five people like
me we just kind of go out we get the
shots that we need however we can and
run away before the police show up here
you know we had a beach and we had it
locked off there's an eighteen thousand
watt light just kind of like lighting up
the beach at night and it's pretty
surreal you know it's like it's all
really controlled and you can do
anything that you want which is great
it's great for an action movie
especially you don't have to worry about
kicking getting kicked out because you
broke some drywall or something outside
of mortal kombat legacy i understand you
have a youtube channel and one of your
videos which we creates a fight scene in
Star Wars when viral would more than
half a million views how did that come
about I wanted to do a I wanted to get a
GoPro for a while now and I realized
that there's an untapped market of GoPro
fight scenes and I realize that doing a
fight scene with a GoPro which is
basically a camera that's about this big
and you can put on your chest or on your
head or anywhere really but the idea is
that it's tiny so you could put it here
and do a first-person fight scene so you
would see the hands fighting and doing
the blocks or you know hitting people
with weapons and I always liked seeing
those when they come out but they're
they're usually um therefore they're few
and far between and I realize nobody's
done a lightsaber fight and that's like
perfect for this kind of thing and that
night when i realized that i went out i
got a GoPro the next day i was thinking
like if we don't do this now somebody
else is going to do it before us and so
we just picked a spot behind our gym i
know some friends from the the the
Golden Gate nights they you know they
showed up and they had all their Star
Wars Iran they said what kind of costume
you want is I gotta dress me up like a
Jedi and then we have Darth Vader show
up and don't they talk anyway yeah got
my bed Vader outfit you pull out this
huge box put it on he and his red Sabre
I have my
uh the blue one and they choreograph the
sword work and I choreographed some of
the other things like the force pole and
then messing with the the console and
I'm Bader's chess because nobody's done
that and and then we went and shot in
took a half hour a half hour just to get
it all just get it all out perfect just
get all perfect and we only had a half
hour or two because that GoPro battery
dies really quick and like you can't you
can't review GoPro footage without the
LCD screen and I didn't buy the LCD
screen for it so all we could do is view
it live on an iPad so yeah this is fun
though and I can't wait to do another
one we want to do a sequel and we've got
other ideas in mind what other ideas you
have in mind oh I don't know if I want
to give that away I do want to do
something with a zombie though I think
that the zombie is not their zombie
potential there with GoPros now let's
get back to your beginnings uh what
inspired you to become a stuntman I
think that the main inspiration had to
be Jackie Chan I discovered him late in
life like martial arts I discovered late
in life I came from a small town and so
you know when I was 16 or 17 I saw my
first Jackie Chan film and you know I
just got so into it I would travel down
to Chinatown which is like a four-hour
drive I would go there every other
weekend just to buy vcds back when video
CDs were like a thing and yes I remember
yeah you get Hong Kong films on these
like CDs basically and the video quality
was terrible but that was the only way
that I could see really rare Hong Kong
martial art movies and and then I but
the first thing i did was i just found
the most hardcore jackie chan movie i
could find what she's drunk and master
too and it ended up being like the best
of all of the Hong Kong films that I
ever saw after that and while watching
and I remember I was thinking like how
could a guy like me do this would it be
possible and I just went for it and when
people ask me how do you get into stunt
work I say you just got to pick up a
camera and go the more you wait for
people to help you push your career like
the longer it will take and the more
you're gonna annoy people by being needy
now I hate to say it but that's just how
it goes now especially since everybody
can go get a camera and make their
video you know nobody's patient with
anyone who just says like well you know
I don't want to make a movie why don't
you just fill me but you just got to do
it yourself that's what we did for 12
years why is it important for you to
transition from mainstream entertainment
to YouTube well I wouldn't say that I've
done very much mainstream I've actually
my presence has mostly been on YouTube
that's how I was discovered and got in
the mortal kombat and then I'm kind of
like going back to YouTube again but
like we're trying to hit it bigger this
time with YouTube now that the star wars
video came out I think we have a better
idea of how to actually be more
successful on YouTube I want to do both
I think that I think that there's room
for both for any person who wants to
pursue a career and stunt work or if you
just want to do one that's perfectly
fine the thing about YouTube is that
it's a it's really a it's it's great for
really creative people and the reason
that it's so great to is because you
don't have to wait for anybody to get
content done you can just make something
and put it online and see how well it
does in the marketplace and I we're very
confident in our product I think that
when we start pushing more stuff on
YouTube it's going to do really well for
us it's not a huge moneymaker from what
I understand but if there is something
there you can make a living doing it and
we want to try that we really want to do
this and then whenever we can take the
mains whenever I can take the mainstream
the mainstream gigs I'll take them
definitely i'd love to i'd love to do
both what does the future hold for the
action martial arts onra on youtube i
think that the martial arts genre on
youtube really needs to it has a lot of
growing to do right now i think we're
really people are just kind of getting
their feet wet with filming fight scenes
and putting sound effects and putting it
to pool music shooting it well that's
definitely that that's really essential
and without that the fight scene is just
not going to hold up they're going to
suck but then what really needs to
happen is martial art fight scenes need
go beyond the martial arts when I say
that I mean they need to go beyond the
martial art moves fight scene between
two people can only go so far if the
focus is just on the moves if there's
actual story if there's some way to
connect with the audience in a very
meaningful way that fight scene
quadruples and impact it just makes it
so much better and I don't see it a
whole lot right now I see a lot of
people doing really amazing martial art
movies but they're not very good
storytellers third they don't do very
much comedy you know the comedy is just
kind of like on the nose it's not
actually good jokes I think that the
future is bright obviously you can only
really get better I would think and I
think that YouTube will be the place to
go for good fight scenes because as we
keep seeing that big mainstream films
are often so big that you don't really
get a good fight scene anymore some of
the time you actually need the smaller
scale projects to get a good fight scene
otherwise it's like well if we have if
you have a 50 million dollar budget
you're not going to spend it on a fight
scene you're going to spend it on a car
chase with a bunch of guns and
explosions and stuff like that and you
lose the fight scene so there's a place
for the low-budget action movie and
martial arts fits that so well and as we
keep seeing budgets balloon bigger and
bigger and Hollywood in Asia to as the
budget to bigger we kind of lose the
fight scene and so it's going to be up
to the YouTube people and the
independent film people in general that
released dvds and blu-rays on to the
market it's going to be up to them to
make the good fights which action
channels on YouTube do you follow some
of my favorite YouTube action guys are
all right Ulrich brothels in Germany and
his channel is called flat coin I think
he does really really good stuff he does
like good visual effects with martial
arts lazy brown productions in Chicago
there another independent stunt team and
they do great stuff and they do a whole
different slate of kinds of fight scenes
really high energy the young masters I
think they're also in Germany and they
do amazing Hong Kong style fight scenes
and I think there's some of the best at
it and then got there there are so many
because if i could give you one more i
would say Andy long
we win who is kind of it is his group is
called the Magnificent fighters and also
in Germany Jeremy's got a lot of these
and Andy made a big step recently of
going into Chinese zodiac and he's in
the end fight Chinese zodiac and so he
he went from being you know like
independent stunt guy just kind of
making his own videos all the time to
handing Jackie Chan a DVD and saying hey
can I get thrown around by you a little
bit and sure enough he's in Chinese
zodiac and he did it in up so thank
thanks for talking to us Eric thank you
we synced together my love key although
we tried seems we just can't find a
harmony we just don't fit each other's
frequencies